angelina jolie and her co-stars in the
new marvel movie eternals gemma chan
selma hayek and lauren ridloff had to
cancel their appearance at elle's women
in hollywood event on tuesday due to a
possible covet 19 exposure a source
tells et that 20 minutes before the l
ceremony was slated to begin disney told
elle that the actresses wouldn't be able
to attend quote because of this the cast
has been forced to pull the plug on the
rest of their live appearances until
they are fully cleared our source adds
that disney is now scrambling because of
the scare in a statement on tuesday
disney confirmed the news of the
possible exposure adding quote while all
of our talent have tested negative out
of an abundance of caution we are
pivoting to virtual appearances rather
than in-person events according to elle
the a-list stars who made up four of the
night's nine honorees were set to give
speeches at the gala event
and their absence was noted in the
opening remarks by elle's
editor-in-chief nina garcia this all
comes less than a day after all four
actresses appeared together on the red
carpet at the premiere of the superhero
flick in hollywood on monday it's
unknown if the premiere was the site of
the covit exposure
the event was a family affair for angie
and selma i'm a mom
so that's my it's my thing angelina
walked the carpet with her kids 20 year
old maddox 16 year old zahara 15 year
old shiloh and 13 year old twins vivian
and knox who all wore vintage looks some
straight out of their famous mom's
closet
my kids are all mixed with like vintage
and my old oscars these are my old oscar
dress we did all vintage and like
upcycled my old stuff and while her kids
were by her side for the film's big
night she said they weren't exactly
thrilled about the gold spandex ensemble
she wears on the big screen would you
want to see your mother wearing that
listen if you got it you got it
they haven't seen the movie so i think
they're gonna but i mean your mom walks
in in a full spandex gold outfit with
gold hair and you just think what do you
do for a living get back in your robe
salma hayek also hit the red carpet with
her 14 year old daughter valentina and
opened up to e.t about taking on the
role of the superhero who was originally
written as a man in the comic book the
movie is based on
for me
it's a shocker because it's a shocker in
many ways
just to know that you know in your 50s
you're going to be
you know and a hero you know an
action hero a superhero
in the marble family
and then on top of it
that it used to be a man that they just
turn it into a woman i mean if somebody
told me this
five years ago
i would have laughed so hard and here we
are
anything is possible
real quick didn't when you told your
daughter you were was she impressed at
all where is she
she's hiding behind me
hello is mom cool at all for this or is
it still kind of like oh mom um she's
cool
you